Marie writes my husband charges me 41%
of my pay for rent and
utilities what I work 30 hours a week
and only make
$35,000 I used about $80,000 to pay my
husband's debts to help him be debt free
several times over the past seven years
but he doesn't stay debt free he even
racked up 14,000 behind my back I refuse
to pay the debt off after that I don't
have the money to help him nor do I want
to we keep our money separate now till
he cleans up his debt and learns to
handle money uh Marie if I was you or
you were my sister or you were my close
friend I would tell you to um head
directly to a marriage counselor or a
therapist by yourself not a marriage
counselor because he's not going to go
because you're you're married to a
seven-year-old who has um access to
adult toys and adult financial
institutions